The demand for greater Asian representation
in Hollywood has never been higher than it
is today.
Luckily, with Shang-Chi and the Legend of
the Ten Rings, Marvel seems to be putting
their money where their mouth is.
Here's what you need to know before you see
Shang-Chi.
Like every other project in Marvel's Phase
4, Shang-Chi has taken a long and bumpy road
to movie theaters.
The film was initially set to kick off on
February 12th, 2021, making it the third theatrical
release for the Phase 4 lineup, after Black
Widow and Eternals.
That was announced all the way back in 2019,
however, when nobody had any idea what the
future held.
Obviously, 2020's COVID-19 pandemic turned
the world upside down, and basically every
studio in Hollywood ground to a halt, including
Marvel.
Both WandaVision and The Falcon and the Winter
Soldier hit Disney+ before their feature-length
cousins could return to theaters.
And then, after a whole lot of reshuffling,
Shang-Chi battled its way to the #2 spot on
the new theatrical release calendar, sliding
in between Black Widow and Eternals.
As it stands, The Legend of the Ten Rings
is expected to hit theaters on September 3rd,
2021.
Marvel has apparently heard the longtime cry
for diversification of not only cast but crew
as well, as the studio has chosen Asian-American
filmmaker Destin Daniel Cretton to helm Shang-Chi.
He joins Eternals director Chloe Zhao as the
first filmmakers of Asian descent to join
the MCU in Phase 4.
Cretton's standout project so far is the 2013
film Short Term 12, a story about troubled
teenagers and their carers living together
in a group home.
Much of Shang-Chi's comics history is checkered,
to say the least, featuring a number of racist
"Oriental mysticism" tropes and "Yellow Peril"
villains.
Bringing on talent of actual Asian heritage
is a positive sign that Marvel Studios is
interested in reflecting the real world more
accurately.
Casting Asian actors is all well and good,
of course — but placing the movie's creative
vision in the hands of a director of Asian
descent is an even better way of avoiding
the mistakes made by the earliest Shang-Chi
comics.
Chinese-Canadian actor Simu Liu was introduced
at Marvel's SDCC 2019 panel as Shang-Chi less
than a week after getting cast.
He was born in Harbin, China, and immigrated
to a suburb in Toronto, when he was 5 years
old.
Liu is best known for his role as the former
delinquent son Jung in Kim's Convenience,
a sitcom he recently criticized, not only
for its premature cancelation, but also for
the way in which many of the Asian actors
were treated by the show's white creators.
Liu also guest-starred as Taiwanese noodle
seller Willie in the 100th episode of ABC's
Fresh off the Boat, which aired in April 2019.
The actor has himself underlined the need
for more Asian representation in the MCU,
first tweeting such sentiments back in 2014.
In 2019, he bought out a Toronto theater for
a screening of Awkwafina's film The Farewell,
citing the need for greater representation
for Asian actors.
Going forward, it seems like the MCU couldn't
ask for a more passionate and devoted champion
for the franchise.
To many Western moviegoers, the name Tony
Leung won't be immediately familiar, but he's
one of the most high-profile and celebrated
actors in the Hong Kong film industry.
Leung's career dates all the way back to the
'70s, and he's starred in everything from
rom-coms to thrillers to martial arts movies.
During his long and storied career, Leung
has won a number of prestigious Hong Kong
Film Awards and earned Best Actor at the 2000
Cannes Film Festival for his leading role
in Wong Kar-wai's In the Mood for Love.
In short: he's a big deal.
For Shang-Chi, Leung has been cast as the
film's antagonist: the Mandarin.
This, of course, is a subversion of the fake
Mandarin played by Ben Kingsley in Iron Man
3.
"It's just a role.
The Mandarin, you see, it's not real."
The 2014 short film Marvel One-Shot: All Hail
the King first revealed that there was indeed
a very real Mandarin operating from the shadows.
According to the trailers for Shang-Chi, it
seems Leung's character is the leader of the
Ten Rings organization, the criminal organization
that debuted in the first Iron Man movie.
In Shang-Chi, it appears that the Mandarin
has trained his son, Shang-Chi, to become
an assassin — and now he's ready for our
hero to take his place in the family business.
Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings
will find its titular hero out and about in
the normal world.
Sure, he was trained as an assassin by his
villainous father, but Shang-Chi doesn't want
anything to do with his criminal group.
Instead, he's spending his days in San Francisco,
living out a normal life and hanging out with
his BFF and co-worker Katy — who's played
by none other than Awkwafina.
Awkwafina broke into the entertainment world
as a rap artist in 2014 with her debut album
Yellow Ranger, followed in 2018 by an EP entitled
In Fina We Trust.
Not content to sit on her laurels, she turned
her eye to acting, making her major breakthrough
in 2018 with the one-two combo of Ocean's
8 and Crazy Rich Asians.
The very next year found her starring in The
Farewell, a drama about a Chinese-American
family heading overseas to pay one last visit
to their dying matriarch.
The movie also features Hong Kong action legend
Michelle Yeoh, who plays Jiang Nan, the hero's
ally and mentor, Fala Chen as Jiang Li, his
mother, and Meng'er Zhang as Xialing, Shang-Chi's
sister.
Meanwhile, Ronny Chieng is playing Shang-Chi's
friend, Jon Jon, and Florian Munteanu will
appear as the intimidating Razor Fist.
After much speculation and a blink-and-you'll-miss-it
trailer appearance, Doctor Strange actor Benedict
Wong confirmed that his character, Wong, will
also be featured in the movie.
Not much else is known right now, but you
can bet your bottom dollar that a few more
familiar faces will show up before those credits
roll.
As you might imagine, the Ten Rings themselves
are going to play a pretty big part in Shang-Chi's
plot.
But what exactly are they?
Well, there are two interpretations to take
into account here, and it's looking like both
will be relevant for the movie's story.
Longtime MCU fans doubtlessly know that the
Ten Rings is a terrorist organization that
kidnapped Tony Stark way back in Iron Man.
It's also revealed in Ant-Man that the group
is very interested in buying Darren Cross'
weaponized Yellow Jacket technology.
They're sort-of featured in Iron Man 3 as
well, claiming responsibility for a number
of explosions across the U.S.
Of course, it turns out the Ten Rings organization
has nothing to do with these events, and the
so-called Mandarin leading them is really
an alcoholic actor being manipulated by a
psychotic businessman.
But now, it looks like we're getting the real
Ten Rings — and this appears to be a bunch
of people you really don't want to be messing
with.
However, there's another meaning behind the
name "Ten Rings."
In the comics, the Ten Rings are magical pieces
of jewelry that imbue special powers to the
user.
They're the Mandarin's primary weapons, and
each performs a different type of attack,
ranging from fire and ice beams to matter
and mind control.
The movie version of the rings are more like
bracelets worn on the user's arms, but their
powers appear to be similar to their comic
book counterparts.
Expect them to play a pivotal role in Shang-Chi's
story.
Long before the trailers for Shang-Chi hit
the internet, there were rumors that the Marvel
movie might also be a martial arts tournament
film.
In fact, a few years ago, Murphy's Multiverse
claimed to have seen a casting call for "tournament
announcers."
Now that two trailers for the movie have been
released, it seems pretty clear that there
will indeed be some kind of tournament featured
in the movie — in which Shang-Chi will battle
his own sister, Xialing.
This tourney is also the setting for a showdown
between two familiar MCU faces: the sorcerer
Wong and the Incredible Hulk villain known
as the Abomination.
This kind of setting makes sense, of course,
as Destin Daniel Cretton has drawn influence
from a variety of martial arts films for Shang-Chi
— including the graceful wuxia stylings
of Crouching Tiger, Hidden Dragon and the
more frenetic pacing of Jackie Chan's action
flicks.
Everyone knew that Shang-Chi was going to
be an action flick.
After all, the original comic book character
was inspired by the legendary Bruce Lee.
[Yelling]
However, judging by the trailers, it looks
like the movie might also be dipping its toe
into the fantasy genre, too.
One trailer, for example, sees Shang-Chi encountering
a gigantic dragon.
Word has it that this massive beast is called
"the Great Protector," and will assist our
hero with its "benevolent power."
In addition, the movie's trailers have offered
a few glimpses of some huge lions, which could
be a nod to the Chinese guardian lions that
guard Imperial landmarks such as tombs and
palaces.
On top of all that, a few leaked toys seem
to be indicating that a Dijiang might show
up somewhere in the film.
These are furry, faceless creatures with wings
that, according to Chinese legend, are perpetually
confused and love to sing and dance.
Could we be about to see the Marvel Cinematic
Universe's first ever twenty-minute karaoke
dance sequence?
Here's hoping.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.